this is a production of cornell
university
perfect okay cool so i like to walk
around a little bit hopefully that's
okay
um so plant roots i assume most you in
this room know what plant roots are
right
but what you may not know is that there
are different types of plant roots and
these different types of plant roots
have different functional roles in the
environment and we think that these
different functional roots or different
roots with different functionalities
lead to different associations of
microorganisms
and today i'm going to be talking about
two separate projects where we've
generated some evidence to show that
appears to be the case
so plant roots
plant roots i probably don't have to
convince anyone in this room that plant
roots are incredibly important for a
number of different ecosystem services
including nutrient cycling and carbon
cycling
in particular the fine roots of a plant
they disproportionately impact carbon
cycling despite their very tiny size
um and we also see roots as you know
being is really important for soil
stability you know we see them as a
little bit as ecosystem engineers um you
know as the plant root is growing
through the soil profile you know
they're able to create poor space from
weather rocks and things like that
but and i love this little quote here we
are still only beginning to explore the
complex relationships between root
traits and functions and this is only a
quote from a couple of years ago
and one of the reasons to this
is possibly due to how roots or fine
roots were traditionally studied
so in a traditional sense what we used
to do is we used to go dig up some roots
and we applied what we call a a diameter
sort of cut off approach or this is the
traditional approach where everything
under an arbitrary sort of size diameter
gets considered as one unit or one
functional unit and we consider that as
one sample
now the problem with that as you can see
here is we have all these different
numbers so we have one two three and
four and these different numbers
represent different root orders
and so these are counted by starting
from the most distally produced roots
which are the first order and counting
backwards towards the middle of the root
system or the stem of the root system if
you will and so we have our first second
and third orders here
now with this sort of traditional
approach or this diameter cutoff
approach
it made between species comparisons
quite difficult and the reason for this
is because of the vast diff uh the vast
sort of diversity of morphologies of
root systems in the in the world right
or in the environment and so here we
have two different tree species that um
i've taken from my study up the top here
uh this is the tulip tree and down the
bottom here i believe this is maple but
i could be wrong
and so um so if we were to apply this
sort of traditional cutoff approach
what that may mean is
with the toiletry at the top here we may
select everything from this sort of
branch down but with the bottom tree
species here we may select the entire
thing so you can see that clearly
there's very difference there's a lot of
differences in the morphology here so it
doesn't really facilitate these species
to species comparisons
now one of the sort of newer ways of
classifying fine roots is using this
functional classification approach or an
order based approach where we have these
groupings based on how based on what the
fine groups actually do in the
environment and so we have a broad
grouping here which are absorptive fine
roots and these are typically the first
and second order fine roots and then we
have another broad group which is the
transport of fine roots and these are
typically things that are four five and
higher and so we have these two broad
classifications here
and i mentioned before that they do a
whole bunch of different functional
roles in the environment and so what
we're looking at here is six different
measures um or different uh different
measures of functionality or different
metrics
um for different fine routes and so what
we have on the x-axis is we have root
order so we go from first up to four and
sometimes to five and on the y-axis we
just have a difference functional
measure and you can see that with
increasing root order so as we go higher
number here we get to more transportive
capacity so with a higher root order we
start to get less uptake capacity we get
less respiration we get less mycorrhizal
colonization and on the flip side as we
go up towards the transporter fine roots
we get more transport of capacity hence
the name
greater life spans and greater cn ratios
so we're seeing these very different
functional roles for these fine roots
and traditionally they would have been
classified as one unit together using
the
two diameter two millimeter diameter
cutoff approach
now when we redefine roots in this way
so going from this traditional cutoff
approach to more of a functional order
based approach we get far better
estimates of nutrient and carbon cycling
in the environment
it also facilitates study to study
comparison so we're able to compare
different morphologies to each other
and that's all fine and dandy right but
i'm here i'm not a root biologist right
so i think this is cool whatever but i'm
a microbiologist so my interest here is
how do these different functional roles
impacts microbiologists you know where
are these microbial relationships
changing because we're seeing different
functional roles these find roots in the
environment
and so before i get too heavy into the
microwave side i just want to have some
introduction here
so the plant rib microbiome the
microbiome is simply just all of the
microbes in or on an organism or in the
environment as well as their combined
genetic content
for the plant root microbiome
a lot of these microbial associations
are absolutely vital for
healthy plant functioning
and so um they're very important for
plant growth a lot of these
microorganisms bring in nutrients for
the plant
and this can be particularly important
in agricultural settings um you know for
things like biomass or yield
they're really important for plant
health so a lot of these plants would
just not thrive at all or grow very well
without these microbial associations and
we'll talk about some of these key
microbes in a second
and they're really important for plant
defenses and some of the ways these
microbes help is that they just take up
spec like physical space to stop
pathogens from colonizing and stopping
them from getting in and they a lot of
microorganisms like to produce compounds
which antagonize or harass other
microorganisms like pathogens and it
stops them from also colonizing and
causing damage so a very important
system here and it's a very intricate
and
i dare say ancient sort of association
or like relationships here
um so
before we go further i just want to very
briefly mentioned uh
break down the root microbiome into the
different compartments because it's a
very sort of dynamic and
complex environment and so what we're
looking at here is a plant root
with its tightly attached soil on the
outside so this is just like a cross
section of a plant room and so there's a
whole bunch of different compartments
and the reason for this is the plant has
different degrees of influence on the
microorganisms based on the
on the compartment it associates with
and so for our first compartment we have
the endosphere this is all of the
microbes that exist within the plant
root itself
we have the rhizoplane this is the
microorganisms that exist on the surface
of the plant root so you have this
yellow sort of outline here
we have the rhizosphere and the
rhizosphere are right here the wild west
because the definitions of the horizons
here have been absolutely ludicrous for
the last decade and people just do
whatever they feel like right
but
it seems to be we're coming to a bit
more of a consensus that the rhizosphere
is the tightly attached soil on the root
itself and this typically means you need
to wash the soil off the root surface so
it's not like the shaken sort of soil or
anything like that in this schematic
like i was saying the wild west back in
the day the rhizosphere used to be
everything that you can see here but
that's not quite true anymore
and lastly we have the ectorizosphere
and that is the rhizoplane which is the
surface attached microorganisms as well
as the tightly attached soil so the
rhizosphere so it's a blending of the
rhizoplane and the rhizosphere
now in a very simple sense
plants will send carbon down to their
roots to encourage these microbial
interactions and this carbon is usually
in the form of exodus or other types of
rhizo-deposits and what happens is the
microbes they sense these carbon they
sense this carbon they go into that
environment and then they can colonize
right and typically not always not all
microorganisms are beneficial but
typically these microorganisms then will
provide something back in return and
it's typically in the form of nutrients
so things like phosphate or other forms
of nitrogen
now the best or the most well-known
system of this is the mycorrhizal fungal
system and so here we have two broad
groups of mycorrhizal fungi we have the
ectomycorrhizal fungi and the arbuscular
mycorrhizal fungi
for the ectomycorrhizal fungi they grow
between the cells of the plant root so
it creates a sort of like a net it's
pretty cool to look at under a
microscope and then we have the
arbuscular mycorrhizal fungi which grow
within the cells of the plant root so
again very ancient sort of associations
here and so these fungi associate with
the plant root and they grow out into
the environment and that increases the
surface area of the plant root because
they can bring back water they can bring
back nutrients and the plant thrives
because of that
um so
what exactly is the problem here right
the problem is microbiologists like me
we've been using this traditional
approach for a very long time where we
just take roots and we homogenize these
roots and then we just say that's our
sample right and that's our signal that
we're measuring
and here this is really well highlighted
by a colleague of mine suzanne
fleischmann who's currently putting
together a big review about different
methods of
root microbial sort of
techniques and she did a big deep dive
into the literature and what we're
looking at here is a pie chart
and
looking at studies that separated out
their roots prior to microbial analyses
and you can see that the vast majority
of these studies 90 and there's an
updated figure which is about 93 so over
90 of these studies do not separate out
their roots prior to microbial analysis
so this is a big problem wow this is a
big problem in my field at the moment
where we're just homogenizing roots
and so given that i've talked about how
these fine roots differ based on a whole
bunch of different metrics we're talking
about respiration morphology nutrient
water flux you know all of these
different metrics they do change by
different fine roots and given that
do we not kind of expect that maybe
these would represent unique
microenvironments for microbial
colonization
and so to explore this
we started off a project and we had a
couple of different hypotheses
so our first hypothesis was that find
roots with different functionality so
like our absorptive find roots and our
transported fine roots they would house
separate or distinct bacterial
compositions
and because of the greater sort of
metabolic capacity of the absorptive
fine roots we hypothesized that we'd
actually see taxa or bacteria that are
really well known for like rapid carbon
usage we thought we'd see more of those
in that type of environment
we expected that we'd see stronger
microbial filtering in that because
we're seeing so much flux in this
environment that the host might have a
stronger selective pressure on the
surrounding microorganisms in that
environment
and lastly because again of the greater
metabolic flux here we'd expect that the
microbial carrying capacity would be
greater so there'd be greater abundance
of bacteria there
and so to explore these hypotheses
we used a at the time a 23 year old
common garden plantation originally made
with 16 different tree species um it was
built with a complete randomized block
design so here we have the top of the
common garden the front of the common
garden
this is out at the rock springs
agricultural
farm out at penn state university and
it's run by dave eisenstadt at the
moment um here we have some of the
sampling team and this is terry bell my
old advisor here
um
we chose six different tree species to
get a mixture of coarse and thin rooted
tree species as well as half like 3 em
or 3 em and 3 am so arbuscular and
ectomycorrhizal associating fungi
so here we have some nice different
pictures of the tree roots here and you
can see the morphologies are quite
distinct from each other
and so
from these pictures it's a bit hard to
see because the the boxes are quite
small but the absorptive fine roots are
highlighted in orange here and these
orange boxes
the what we call the intermediary fine
roots are in green and intermediary is
just it's on its way to be a transporter
fine root so the morphology changes a
bit and we have the blue one here which
is the transporter fine roots
and you can see that particularly for
the tool tree down the bottom here the
transport defined route is very distinct
but for other trees like the pine tree
or walnut you can see it's not really
you know you could very easily
homogenize that into a sample
and so we collected these roots we
sorted them into absorptive which is one
and two intermediary which is three and
transformative which is four and five uh
fine roots we also took bulk soil so we
could actually look at how the
surrounding microbes were being
recruited or the selective pressure
being placed on those by the host
we sonicated these roots to release the
ectorizosphere so in this case we're
looking at the rhizoplane mixed in with
the rhizosphere so the two together
and we also did for a few of these
samples we did some flow cytometry to
look at that idea of microbial carrying
capacity so to quantify abundance
and so
this is a compatibility issue but this
should be a nicer color but it doesn't
matter but anyway the colors carry
through the rest of the talk anything in
red is an absorptive fine root anything
in green is intermediary anything in
blue is a transported fine root
in this case the purple are bulk soil
bacteria
and so what we're looking at here this
is an ordination or a constrained
analysis of principal
principle coordinates um and each dot is
a bacterial composition or a microbiome
if you want to conceptualize it in that
way
and these dots are plotted based on how
similar or dissimilar they are to
another sample all right so this gives
us an idea of how similar or dissimilar
these bacterial compositions are from
each other
and what we can see is that we get nice
clustering of bacterial compositions or
microbiome samples if you will based on
different
fine root functionalities so they're
separating out based on the fine roots
they associate with
and the bulk soil is also different to
the root associated microbes and we saw
this pattern for all of the tree species
that we selected as well
and so
we're seeing differences according to
root order for all of these tree species
now one thing that we notice is that
when you look at these ordinations you
can see these the purple ones here the
bulk soil ones there's a general sort of
pattern where they appear to
sort of cluster a little bit closer to
the transporter fine route so the blue
ones here it's probably the most obvious
for maybe this one down here which is
oak
and so we wanted to look into that a
little bit deeper to see how that's
impacting so because this sort of
indicates that the plants having less of
a selective pressure on those
microorganisms so we looked into this a
little bit more
and what we're looking at here
these are bray curtis dissimilarities
relative to bulk soil
and what that means is i took a the
bacteria from a root and i took the bray
curtis values relative to soil so i can
see how similar they are to each other
and the way this plot works is anything
closer to zero on the y-axis means that
it's more similar to bulk soil okay so
it's actually the opposite in your brain
you think it'd be higher but no it's the
opposite okay so anything higher up
means it's more dissimilar and so what
we see here is that for absorptive and
intermediary fine roots they have
bacteria that are more dissimilar to the
surrounding bulk soil whereas the
transported fine groups here their
bacteria are more similar to the
surrounding bulk soil so this is
indicating to us that there is less
selective pressure being applied on
transported fine roots on the
surrounding sort of bacteria in the
environment or in the soil
so what about the taxa who exactly are
driving these patterns between different
route orders and so here we're looking
at different phyla um which is just a
taxonomic rank uh these are all for
bacteria and so there's a whole bunch of
different taxes here most of them don't
mean anything but the ones that i really
want to point out are these three here
the beta proteobacteria the
acidobacteria and the bacteria deities
right now the way this plot works is
this is relative abundance delta change
and this is relative to absorptive fine
roots so what that means is anything
that is
in the negative direction
means there's more of it in absorptive
fine roots and anything in the positive
direction means it's more in that
specific fine root so in this case the
green is the intermediary and the blue
is the transportive does that kind of
make sense to you guys so anything
negative means more in absorptive
anything positive means more in that
specific root order
and so what we see here is that the beta
proteobacteria and the bacteria deities
there's more of those in the absorptive
fine roots now that's a really cool
pattern because
a long time ago back in 2007 an awesome
microbiologist by noah fiera
set out to figure out some general sort
of functional roles of bacteria in the
environment and what he found was that
the beta proteobacteria and the bacteria
deities
correlate really positively well with
carbon mineralization so these tax are
really good at using carbon and breaking
it down really quickly
and in the exact same paper this is
perfect for my study actually
what he found was that the acidobacteria
had the opposite trend so it had a
negative relationship with carbon
mineralization
and so what we're seeing in this study
here is a perfect parallel
of our data with the previous literature
where we see more taxa that are known
for carbon mineralization or rapid
carbon usage as being more
more abundant or relatively abundant in
the absorptive fine groups and this
makes sense because absorptive fine
roots metabolic flux so we should expect
to see more of those taxes there
um so this sort of tells us that we can
start to separate out the taxa into you
know
at least it sort of indicates that
copiotrophic bacteria so things that
like to use lots of different carbon or
easy to use carbon resources and they
grow really quick we see them more uh
preferentially colonizing the absorptive
fine roots relative to the transported
pine roots
um
so that's cool so we're seeing
differences in the tax cell we see
differences in composition how about the
carrying capacity the physical abundance
and so
this is flow cytometry data on the
y-axis we're looking at cells per gram
of dry root and on the x-axis we have
our different fine roots so we have
absorptive intermediary and
transportative
we did this on three different tree
species
and what we found is that for two of the
three tree species so we have
walnut here and pine tree
we saw greater cellular greater
bacterial abundance in the absorptive
fine roots relative to our other fine
roots so it's particularly obvious here
in the pine tree we're seeing way more
bacteria in our absorbed defined roots
this again makes sense absorb defined
roots metabolic flux should be more
carbon there right we didn't see this
for the tool tree um this could be
because the tulip tree is such an
ancient species that their roots are
really really funny they're like little
clubs so maybe something funny is going
on there but the error bars are quite
large so it could also just be just
didn't work out
but at least the general trend we see is
that a more bacterial abundance in
absorptive fine roots
i mentioned that we had picked
uh half am and half em associating trees
um and so i'm just going to very briefly
talk about that pattern too because
people love mycorrhizal fungi and so for
each of our
fine roots absorptive intermediary and
transportive we do see distinct
clustering for am and em associating
trees so this is a broad pattern that
we're seeing as well um the black dots
here are arbuscular associating trees
and the triangle purple ones here are
ectomycorrhizal associating trees
and so this is where i plug a good
friend of mine kailyn yates who
published a lot more on this sort of
pattern about the mycorrhizal fungi and
how they're influencing the tree
property so if you're interested in more
of that mycorrhizal sort of influencing
soil highly recommend going and reading
his paper there
in terms of the taxa driving the patents
between the two the one taxes that stood
out the most was acidobacteria and it
was over represented in the ectomark
arousal trees and again there's perfect
literature a couple years back that
showed that
a muscular mycorrhizal fungi are known
to antagonize acidobacteria a little bit
and so the fact that we're seeing more
of them here in our em associating trees
makes sense so it's again perfect
parallel to the literature here
so just to summarize the first project
here we see differences in bacterial
composition according to fine root order
a lot of the taxes that drive these
differences are copiotrophic in nature
so things that like to break down carbon
really easily or grow really quickly
we saw differences in microbial
filtering where the absorptive fine
roots applied a greater selective
pressure on the surrounding bacteria in
that
environment um oh yeah and we also saw
differences in microbial carrying
capacity where we had greater bacterial
abundance in our absorbed defined roots
so after finishing this project we're
like well you know just like any science
project you finish there's a billion
questions that you need to answer right
and so we published this it got a lot of
attention we're super happy with that
but we had a whole bunch of questions
still remaining so the first one was in
that first study
we studied the ectoryosphere which is a
mixture of the riser plane and the
rhizosphere right so the question here
is who which compartment is actually
driving that pattern is it the rise of
cereals or the riser plane or even both
we just don't know right because at the
time we chose to study both at the same
time
secondly
are the microorganisms associating to
different fine roots because of the
resources available at each fine group
is it just simply that there's different
carbon resources that are being pulled
into that environment so we want to have
a look at the metabolomics of this
system as well
and lastly are the microbial functions
different you can get differences in
composition but you may not get
differences in microbial functionality
in the environment so we're like we were
interested in looking in that as well
and so after finishing the first project
i wrote a little grant for one of the
national labs pacific northwest national
laboratory and we managed to get a bit
of funding to do metabolomics and we
work with them to do the second project
here so this is our follow-up study
for this study we chose four different
tree species two am and two am and we
had
two coarse sort of rooted ones and two
thin rooted sort of species
for this study we collected
absorptive and transported fine roots
and we took the rhizosphere and the
rhizoplane from each one
now for the rhizosphere we did amplicon
sequencing
just very briefly amplicon sequencing is
where we use a target gene such as 16s
rrna so the ribosomal gene or its the
its region on one of their ribosomal
genes and it allows us to do high
throughput sequencing to figure out
which bacteria is carrying that specific
copy of this gene
so we did that for the rhizosphere for
the rhizoplane we did a little bit more
work where we also did amplicon
sequencing but in addition to that we
did metagenomics and metagenomics is
where you sequence entire genomes from
the environment so you can get their
functional roles as well and we also
perform metabolomics so we can look at
the resources that were available at the
at the at those sort of micro
environments as well
and so
our hypotheses for this project was
given that we saw the differences in the
ectorizosphere in the first study we
hypothesized that actually the
rhizoplane would probably be driving
most of these differences so we thought
that would be the most important
compartment and we would see these
differences both in composition as well
as microbial function
we
also hypothesized we would see a general
trend where the rhizo plane and the rise
of sphere would be different from each
other at both of the different root
orders so absorptive and our transporter
fine roots
and
we expected that because of the sort of
metabolic flux that goes on in the
absorbed defined rooms we thought we'd
see a lot more like simple sugars things
that are very easy to use
whereas we'd see maybe some more
defensive based compounds in the
transport of fine roots because it's
trying to prevent things from you know
trying to get in and like you know be
pathogenic
and so
the first pattern
what we're comparing here
is i'm comparing
the rhizoplane to the rhizosphere in
each specific root order
and so what we saw was that for the
absorptive fine roots we saw significant
differences between the rhizoplane and
the rhizosphere but we did not see that
for the riser uh for the transport of
fine roofs so the differences between
the root compartments were only seen for
the absorptive fine roots not
transported fine roots
so for this plot here this is just
another ordination
for the different shapes of the squares
here are the rhizo-plane and the
triangles of the rhizosphere
and the different colors are just
different tree species
and so i really like this graph because
it looks like a sort of a mirror copy of
each other because they're different
compartments so it's sort of like being
like pushed up a little bit and that's
just different degrees of host influence
there so we're seeing different microbes
what about the taxer
so
um
some of the taxes that appeared to
differ
between the rhizosphere and the
rhizoplane
one of them was the gamma proteobacteria
now with the recent changes in microbial
taxonomy which i can talk to you for
about for a week because no one was
really happy with it but the beta
proteobacteria that i was talking about
before the one that's very copiotrophic
likes to use those very easy to use
resources they were moved into the gamma
proteobacteria and in fact the gamma
proteobacteria is majority made up of
the beta proteobacteria so the shifts
that we're seeing here are primarily
driven by the beta proteobacteria where
we see more of them in the rhizoplane so
on the surface of the root as opposed to
the rhizosphere
on the other side or on the flip side
there's another sort of class here which
is the various microbial
we see more of this class in the
brazosphere as opposed to the rhizoplane
and a lot of the microorganisms in this
class like to associate with other
organisms so like unicellular sort of
eukaryotes and things like that so it
makes me think that maybe there's more
of these
organisms in the rhizosphere which are
just carrying these microbes as well
right because it's also a hot spot of
activity because we do get a lot of you
know things going on there so you'd have
predators as well and things like that
for this comparison
i was comparing the rhizo plane so the
same root compartment to the rhizoplane
between the absorptive and transported
fine roots or i was comparing the
rhizosphere between the obser between
the absorptive and transported fine
group so it's the same root compartment
just comparing the root orders if that
makes sense yep
and what we found was that the rhizo
plane
was significantly different between the
root orders
but the rhizosphere wasn't
so we're seeing more of a host influence
on the rhizoplane than we are on the
rhizosphere it seems to be a general
influence on the rhizosphere but there's
a more of a spatial pattern for the
rhizo plane
and uh same thing here same sort of
ordination that we're looking at before
in this case the different shapes are
different root orders with the uh
circles here being the absorptive fine
roots and the triangles being the
transported fine roots so we're seeing
differences
with different functional roles for the
riser plane but not the rhizosphere
and what about again the taxa who's
driving these patterns and again our
favorite one gamma proteobacteria which
is
beta proteobacteria really in this at
least in this study
we see way more of that in the
absorptive fine roots as opposed to the
transport defined roots for the
rhizoplane and again this mirrors the
pattern we saw in our first study
because absorb defined roots metabolic
hot spot we'd expect to see more of them
in that environment
for the root metabolome so the resources
available here this is again another
ordination um in this case the shapes
are different root orders we saw
significant differences in the root
metabolomes for the absorptive and
transported fine roots so the resources
available at these different fine roots
are different from each other
a lot of these differences were
primarily driven by sugars which is one
of our hypotheses so things like sucrose
tagatos down here fructose
things like that so the flocks between
those uh was driving a lot of the
differences between these different
route orders
and we also saw some defense compounds
such as catechin which is
i think it's that one there maybe
as being more of that in the transport
of fine groups so again our hypothesis
was on point where we were thinking
those more sort of defensive sort of
compounds in the transported fine routes
and lastly
i had talked about microbial functioning
you can get differences in composition
but the functions may not necessarily
differ from each other
luckily we did see differences in
functioning which is fantastic because
it's a lot of money to do metagenomics
and so for the absorptive fine roots
what we found was that we saw an
over-representation of functions
functions responsible for sugar
transport systems so seeing a lot more
sort of movement of sugar in that type
of environment which makes sense there's
a lot more sugars in that environment as
we saw with our metabolomic starter
on the and we also saw a greater over
representation or greater abundance of
isopeptidases and endopeptidases
on the flip side in the transporter fine
roots we saw uh over representation of
dipeptidases so i'm not entirely sure
why we're seeing this pattern here
probably has something to do with maybe
amino acids or maybe the energy you can
pull from trying to break those things
down
and urea transport which is
completely random and i have no idea why
that's if anyone knows anything about
urea in plant roots definitely let me
know
um
yeah just to summarize those patterns
so we see differences between root
compartments
for absorptive fine roots not
transported fine roots
we saw differences between root orders
for the rhizoplane which is the microbes
on the surface of the plant roots but
not the rhizosphere and these
differences we saw with the rhizoplane
were mirrored by composition and
functional data as well so we see
differences in both
and we also detected differences in the
root metabolome between the different
root orders so absorptive and
transported fine roots and this was
largely driven by differences in sugars
and um in this case a defensive compound
which is catechin
and so what about the implications you
know this is all fine and dandy who
cares right what is this actually what's
the importance of this data
so the first one is is that really each
root order or at least each functional
role
they are unique micro environments for
microbial colonization and so the
sampling methods that you use to study
these root microbial associations are
quite important
i've shown you that the composition and
even the functions can change between
different root orders or groups of root
orders and so
this really highlights how if you
homogenize your roots you can really
mask those signals that you're trying to
detect and these days a lot of people
are trying to do what we call uh
genome-wide association studies where
they look at individual snips which is
just a change in a nucleotide to sort of
link that to specific bacteria or
specific taxa now the problem with that
is those could be quite subtle signals
and so if you are homogenizing your
roots or not really
you know separating them out properly
you could be masking those very subtle
signals so you could be hiding the
things you're trying to detect
and
i love leaving this talk with this quote
here
this is from luke
cormack's paper in 2015 new phytologist
and he said compared with their closest
above-ground analogues
functional divergence between absorptive
and transport-defined roots would be
equivalent to that observed between
leaves and twigs and if i was studying
the leaf microbiome i wouldn't have a
twig in my leaf microbiome and so for
the roots we should definitely be
separating them out as well to really
discover or uncover these types of
relationships or what the roots are
actually doing in the environment
and so before i finish off my talk i
just wanted to very just spend a minute
or two about some of the sort of future
work that we're doing here um which is
very much trying to figure out or
decipher some of these microbial
relationships with plants and so some of
the work we're doing here is looking at
developing what we call synthetic
communities of microorganisms so by
putting in microorganisms that we know
in with a plant we can actually begin to
figure out who's interacting with with
who to look at the feedback and to like
understand
what's important you know what's the
host microbial feedback in this system
what's driving it and so here i love
this picture this is a 96 well plate and
each wall of this plate except for three
of these where they didn't grow there is
a unique bacteria in each one and so
with this lighting it might be a bit
hard to tell but you can start to see
different colors so that bacteria is a
little bit different to this one here
that one's a bit darker so there's all
these different phenotypes there so
we're capturing a big diversity of
microorganisms with this in this case
it's a high throughput culturing system
we're also developing
these techniques in the lab this is
called a flow pot system
where we can actually sterilize the
entire unit itself so that way we don't
get microbial contamination coming
through and so this is just really a
glorified syringe it is a syringe just a
bit more glorified and so the idea of
this is the entire unit can be
sterilized we can sterilize the
substrate we can grow plants in this and
then through the bottom or even the top
if you want but the bottoms be easier
you can push in your own microorganisms
and start to manipulate the system to
figure out what's going on
um lastly as well so many of you may
know that we can only culture maybe one
percent of all microbial diversity in
the environment there's a whole bunch of
things that you just physically can't
grow or we just can't do it with our
current technology
and so we are also running these
experiments where we do these whole
community manipulations where we'll put
in this case soils under different
abiotic stresses
to shift a whole community towards a
certain direction
um or at least adapt to certain
conditions and then we can give those
whole communities all those soils to
plants to see how those how see how
those plants then respond under say
drought stress or under about stress so
it's a whole community sort of inoculum
approach as opposed to individual
microbes here
and lastly just want to plug some
students in the lab this is
gillian gomer and jacob scharfetter and
so our lab is really starting to
try to break down these relationships
between uh hydrology exudation so host
feedback and microbial sort of
interactions and so we've uh well
taran's assembled a fantastic team
actually to start to really uncover or
decipher these relationships to figure
out what's going on and you know what's
going on in this sort of fine scale
system here
i'd love to acknowledge an absolute
massive team of people that have helped
me over the years with these projects
as well as a whole bunch of people from
penn state with particular emphasis on
michaela cenari dave eisenstadt and
terry bell my last postdoc advisor um as
well as a bunch of people from cornell
that was super influential in helping me
sort of interpret some of this data and
sort of like figure out what's going on
as well as the team from the pacific
northwest national laboratory who
performed all the metabolomics and gave
him my grant to do this
as well as the usda for their funding
the us department of energy
and nsf as well
cool thank you
any questions
repairs
you know an important
interface between the
root and soil microbes so have you
looked at the repair morphology of these
different okay definitely yeah i think
you're right root hairs are very very
important in these studies we didn't um
just because there's an extra step and
this is already we're already trying to
move the field towards like separating
out fine roots just in general um i
definitely think uh root hairs have
their own unique sort of interactions
with microorganisms as you're suggesting
we didn't look at that into here but
it's definitely an avenue of exploration
so and i think a lot of people looking
at root hairs it's one of the big thing
at least when i think of microbial
studies people will look at the tips of
roots or root hairs and they'll do a lot
of like microscopy work or chemotaxis
work
but i've not seen sort of bigger trends
where we look at general spatial
patterns on root hairs because that
could be quite interesting as well but
yeah super important anybody from geneva
have any questions
cool looks like i'm being led off easy
yeah so my understanding is that the use
of urea in microorganisms is quite rare
i could be wrong but there's only a
couple of things that i know of off the
top of my head that do this type of
either like bring it in or metabolize it
in some way
it's probably linked maybe
to do with nitrogen cycling and somehow
in some way i know that
with root systems you can get
differences in nitrification and
denitrification at very fine scales so
typically roots will have less
nitrifiers and more denitrifiers so i'm
wondering if it's more related to that
type of system but it's a complete guess
in the dark at the moment
i know for example it's a shame i don't
have the video but i know arbuscular
mycorrhizal fungi when they associate
with plants they will specifically bring
in denitrifying bacteria to the root
surface and so i'm wondering if it all
links up into that system somehow but
it's a complete guess i have no idea why
urea is more of it's there couldn't tell
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu